[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and I'm very excited to talk
about the evolution of Gohan from his
introduction in Dragon Ball Z to his
participation in the ongoing tournament
of power in Dragon Ball super Gohan is
and always was my favorite character in
Dragon Ball and this was solidified for
me when he turned Super Saiyan 2 against
self to this day that is still one of
the most epic moments in Dragon Ball for
me if not the most epic moment but
Goku's first Super Saiyan transformation
is definitely up there if you guys want
to see more videos that explain how
Dragon Ball characters change and evolve
over time smash that like button and
leave a suggestion in the comment
section below
for what character you'd like to see if
you haven't already subscribe and hit
that notification bells so you know the
second we upload a new Dragon Ball video
and follow us on Instagram where we post
daily Dragon Ball and other anime
content obviously if you haven't watched
wrong Ball super there will be spoilers
and without further ado let's do this
Gohan or son gohan son referring to his
family name was born on May 18 in the
Year 757 in the anime chichi originally
wanted to name Gohan Einstein which
makes sense since she clearly wants him
to grow up to become a successful
scholar and professor however when the
baby hears that name he starts to cry
and then chichi suggests Archimedes but
this name also makes the baby cry
finally the baby over here is the name
Gohan and really likes it so Goku and
chichi decide to name their son after
Goku's adoptive grandfather
Goku also makes a hat using the four
star Dragon Ball and gives it to Gohan
to honor the memory of his grandpa Gohan
is spoiled and pampered from a young age
but in one instance Goku accidentally
lets go out Gohan stroller and the
stroller starts rolling downhill and
gets out of control
Goku cannot save Gohan in time Gohan is
gonna hit into a massive tree and this
is when Goku first observes Gohan's head
and powers
Gohan starts crying is surrounded by a
white aura and shoots right through the
giant tree leaving a gaping hole in it
not only is he on harm baby Gohan smiles
when she she checks to see if he's all
right this is a pattern in Gohan's life
that will continue to reoccur
he is pushed into a corner or when he
gets angry he will be able to muster up
incredible strength despite his young
age and inexperience now let's fast
forward to Raddatz arriving on earth
Gohan is now four years old
unlike Goku Gohan is fearful and shy
around people but enjoys petting Master
Roshi's turtle and playing
rock-paper-scissors with a crab
although Goku thinks that he has power
and potential chichi gets mad if Goku
tries to train him so he hasn't pushed
it when Bulma asks Gohan what he wants
to be Gohan says he wants to be a great
scholar rather than a fighter at this
point Gohan has a tail like Goku did
when he was a child he is the only half
saying to be born with a tail since
Goten and Trunks are born with that one
at this point
rabbits shows up and kidnaps Gohan not
as puts Gohan into his space pod but
Gohan manages to break out while Goku
and piccolo are fighting Raddatz Gohan
is enraged when he sees Raddatz
torturing Goku as a result of his anger
his power level shoots up and he
headbutts rat it's hard knocking the
breath animal it is Gohan's mood that
gives Goku and piccolo the opportunity
to finish off Raddatz it is interesting
to note that at one point rat it's his
Scouter measures Gohan's power level
when he's angry at 1307 later Vegeta
reveals that rats is power level was
around 1200 and Goku and piccolo could
barely defeat him together with Gohan's
help
thus Gohan at the age of 4 is already
more powerful than an adult Goku and
piccolo
not to mention Raddatz Gohan's potential
is insane and Dragon Ball continually
reminds us of that Gohan goes on to
train for the first time with piccolo
piccolo has to overcome Gohan's Pampered
ways he leaves him alone in the
wilderness for six months to fend mostly
for himself during this time period
Gohan gazes at the full moon and becomes
a powerful great ape to solve the
problem
piccolo destroys the freaking moon which
is pretty cool
just to be sure it doesn't happen again
piccolo also Yanks off Gohan's tail
although go on is a crying mess at the
beginning he eventually learns to
provide for himself he becomes confident
enough to tease the dinosaur that used
to scare him and even become skilled
enough to slice off me from the
dinosaur's tail to eat after Gohan
learns to fend for himself
piccolo starts training him personally
and he is pretty brutal with his
training
you would have had a heart attack if she
saw it in one instance piccolo pretends
like he's going to help Gohan out of a
rushing stream but kicks him back into
it instead he gives Gohan one of the
biggest bumps I've seen over his right
eye but all the while piccolo is growing
fond of his student and vice versa
although piccolo is tough on Gohan Gohan
thinks that people are wrong about
piccolo and that he is actually a good
person a year passes and a five year old
Gohan needs to help the Z fighters deal
with the two new threats
Vegeta and nappa although Gohan is
better than he was before he still gives
in to fear at times and in his defense
he's a five-year-old fighting above six
foot ten alien with no shirt and a tail
I think most of us would be scared but
nonetheless there are instances where
Gohan taps into his true potential
like when he lands an insanely powerful
kick on nappa sudden can fly through a
boulder it is during this fight that
piccolo sacrifices his own life for
Gohan's jumping in the way of Napa's
attack showing just how fond he has
become with his rivals son this is
probably one of the most touching
moments in Dragonball piccolo admits
that Gohan was the only one he could
open up with and could sincerely
converse with piccolo even sheds tears
it is a beautiful moment that will set
the tone for Gohan and Piccolo's
friendship for the rest of the series
Gohan goes on to play a vital role in
Vegeta's defeat Vegeta creates a power
ball and fires it into the sky in order
to serve as the moon and this allows him
to turn into a great ape after yard Robi
cuts off the genus tail he shrinks back
into his regular form but he still has
fight left in him Gohan has to fight him
and distract him while and incapacitated
Goku passes a spirit bomb onto Crillon
finally Quillin fires the spear bomb a
Vegeta but misses Gohan because he has a
pure heart is able to deflect the spirit
bomb and hit Vegeta with it however
Vegeta is still alive and kicking even
after the damage inflicted on him in the
meantime
Gohan has grown his Saiyan tailback and
he turns into a great ape for a second
time after seeing Vegeta's Power Ball in
the sky
although Vegeta manages to slice off
Gohan steel with an attack Gohan lands
on him while he is still in his grade-a
form and that impact injures Vegeta to
the point that he is unable to continue
fighting once
again Gohan despite being a child has
saved the day and demonstrated his
amazing power
sometime after Vegeta escapes in a space
pod Gohan has a conversation with chichi
that shows how much he has grown and how
much braver he has gotten over the past
year he tells his mom that he's going to
go to Namak no matter what so that he
can help gather than the meki and Dragon
Balls and bring piccolo and the others
back
whereas before he was obedient to Chi
Chi and prioritized being a scholar over
fighting now he is no longer able to be
swayed by chichi chichi keeps trying to
convince Gohan that he cannot go because
he is a child and he has cram school on
lessons but Gohan tells her to shut up
to chi Chi's great shock the once timid
and studious Gohan realizes that he has
to fight and that the lives of the
others and the safety of the planet take
priority over his studies despite the
fact that Gigi thinks Gohan has become a
delinquent Goku is proud and recognizes
that Gohan has truly grown stronger both
physically and mentally on amick Gohan
and krillen see Frieza and his men
killing the Meccans Gohan can't take it
anymore
he kicks the Doria in the face and saves
dendi they managed to lose the Doria and
then they takes Krillin and then Gohan
to grant elder guru the leader of the
namekians the grand elder unlocks
Gohan's hidden potential significantly
increasing his power display his power
increase however Gohan gets beaten badly
by the tough opponents on Namek like
raccoon who almost kills Gohan before
Goku comes to the rescue
later on Gohan as usual snaps after
Frieza in his second form injures
Crillon at this point Frieza claims that
his power level is over 1 million but
Gohan manages to land a great number of
punches and kicks on him followed by
many energy blasts Vegeta is shocked
that Gohan can draw forth so much power
when he becomes angry and even suggests
that he could be the closest to becoming
a Super Saiyan at this point the attacks
bring Frieza to his knees and freeze
admits the attacks hurt but ultimately
Gohan's attempts to defeat Frieza proved
futile in the anime after Frieza smash a
Super Saiyan Goku into the ground
Gohan can no longer sense Goku ski and
assumes he died
Gohan still a 5 year old mind you tells
Bulma to make sure Crellin and piccolo
get back to earth safely while
goes to fight Frieza the evil emperor of
the universe who just supposedly
murdered his super saiyan father
Gohan plans to keep Frieza busy so that
they both die together in the planets
explosion even though Frieza is in his
final form
Gohan manages to get an impressive
number of punches on Frieza and send him
flying to the ground he finishes it off
with a masane KO ha
but unfortunately Frieza doesn't appear
fazed Frieza powers up to 100% and
prepares to kill Gohan but is
interrupted by Super Saiyan Goku who
emerges from the water below Goku takes
up the fight and orders Gohan to run to
safety which he does nonetheless it
speaks volumes about Gohan that he was
willing to sacrifice his life to kill
Frieza even though he is just 5 years
old he's come a long way from the shy
kid who got frightened by practically
everything over a year ago again Gohan's
bravery but also his great potential or
foreshadowed in these instances where he
manages to for a time at least hold his
own against what should be much more
powerful opponents Gohan's insane
potential is made even more apparent in
the cell saga it is worth mentioning
that in the original anime the Garlic
jr. saga takes place after the freezer
saga
however this saga is completely filler
it is not present in the manga or in
Dragon Ball Kai so I won't go into it in
detail suffice to say
Gohan saves the day without go whose
health the saga pretty much reaffirms
Gohan's crazy talent for fighting one
year later trunks comes to the future
and completely wrecks Frieza and his
father three years after that the
androids appear in Gohan is nine years
old the cell saga is significant because
it's the first time that Gohan
completely surpasses the other Z
fighters in strength before he enters
the hyperbolic time chamber Gohan is
behind Goku trunks and Vegeta who are
all already Super Saiyans however a lot
of things happen in the hyperbolic time
chamber
Goku helps Gohan reach Super Saiyan he
gives Gohan a haircut so he doesn't look
like a Super Saiyan 3 ahead of time and
Goku gets a glimpse of even greater
potential in Gohan that will eventually
become Gohan Super Saiyan to form Gohan
is able to transform into a Super Saiyan
after he thinks about all the times he
couldn't save the people he cares about
it is this need to protect the people
that Gohan care
about this seems to be the secret for
unlocking his seemingly unlimited
potential let's keep that in mind for
later anyways Goku and Gohan stay in
their Super Saiyan forms so that it
starts to feel normal when they get out
of the chamber
Goku wears his usual orange and blue
clothes while Gohan asks piccolo to make
him a copy of his purple outfit which is
his way of showing respect to his first
ever mentor after Goku fails to defeat
cell in his Gohan Stern Gohan tells cell
that he doesn't like fighting like his
dad does he points out as we've already
seen that ever since he was a kid when
he got really angry he would lose
control of himself and become stronger
than he could even imagine kind of like
the Hulk
because cel wants a good fight he keeps
trying to make Gohan angry first by
attacking him and then by attacking the
other Z fighters using a bunch of cells
Jr's Android 16 that now a detached head
explains to Gohan that fighting for
righteousness is not a sin and that he
can release his anger he begs Gohan to
protect the natrone animals that the
Android loved but his words are cut
short when cell shatters the head with
his foot this is the last straw for
Gohan he snaps and finally becomes a
Super Saiyan 2 even though we usually
associate Gohan with being kind and
modest his newfound power goes to his
head
Goku begs him to finish sell off but
Gohan says it's too early and that cell
has to suffer more because Gohan's power
goes to his head so I guess the
opportunity to instigate his
self-destruct feature Goku has to
sacrifice his life to save the others he
transports cell to Kai's planet where he
blows up and Gohan blames himself
however cell is not dead he manages to
regenerate and becomes even stronger
because of his Saiyan DNA and even knows
the instant transmission now and uses it
to come back to earth however Gohan is
glad that he gets a chance to finish
sell off himself for what he's done
although his left arm is injured and
rendered useless after he protects
Vegeta from one of cell's attacks Gohan
has enough energy to launch a one-handed
Kamehameha ad sell his command man and
cells command man meat and with Goku
pushing him on and Vegeta distracting
cell Gohan is able to release enough
energy to completely overpower cells
attack and destroy him once and for all
Gohan proves himself to be the most
powerful
fighter and saves the planet but he also
shows that he can get arrogant and make
stupid mistakes when he receives a
massive power seven years pass and Gohan
is now 16 he meets Vidal during the time
period who is also a student at the same
high school he also becomes a superhero
the great Seiya man is born whether
Gohan truly likes fighting or not it is
clear that he enjoys protecting people
but he doesn't want the fame associated
with being a hero so he lets hercule
take credit for cells that feed and he
asks boma to make him the great Sam and
outfit so that no one recognizes him
despite his crime-fighting ways Gohan
prioritized his studies over his
training so his strength has decreased
over time as we know this is pretty much
the same story that we get at the
beginning of Dragon Ball super
nevertheless on the Chi planet he is
able to turn Super Saiyan 2 and pull out
the Z sword Gohan with Goku's help
manages to break the Z sword and elder
Kai comes out and that helps Gohan
unlock his latent potential the ultimate
Gohan sometimes called the mystic Gohan
form in this form Gohan is the most
powerful Z fight even more powerful than
go tank Super Saiyan 3 however he is not
careful and he lets go tanks and piccolo
get absorbed by Super Buu which puts
boos power above Gohan's to make matters
worse Buu catches him off guard and
absorbs him - after Vegeta defeat Super
Buu Goku manages to defeat Kid Buu with
the help of all the Earth's inhabitants
including Gohan who lend their energy
for the super spirit bomb and so Dragon
Ball Z ends with Gohan still being the
strong as Z fighter since no other
transformation besides vegeto could at
this point match Gohan's ultimate form
and then we get to the events of Dragon
Ball super which take place sometime
after kid boos defeat Gohan still wants
to become a scholar and has married the
del at one point Gohan Chargers at
bureaus
but beerus knocks him out effortlessly
later when everyone finds out that they
need five Saiyans to create Super Saiyan
God Vidal reveals that she is pregnant
with Gohan's child so she joins them and
it is enough to turn Goku into a Super
Saiyan God during the golden Frieza Saga
Hanz child pan is born Gohan has finally
become a scholar he is a family man and
he dresses up as great say a man in
order to play with his daughter when
freezes army finally shows up the Z
fighters go to meet them Gohan has
gotten incredibly rusty over the past
few years but thinks he can probably
still go super saiyan
he eventually does turn super saiyan
although he says in his current shape he
cannot even maintain this state for long
and he defeats captain ginyu who is in
Tacomas body however Gohan is no match
for Frieza
despite the fact that freezes in his
base form Frieza fires death beam after
death beam almost killing Gohan but
piccolo once again sacrifices his life
for Gohan's and saves him from a lethal
beam Gohan blames himself for Piccolo's
death since he's gotten so weak that he
couldn't even protect himself let alone
piccolo or anyone else
however Gohan is able to raise enough
energy for Goku to sense him from beerus
his planet and use instant transmission
to return to earth even though Gohan's
body cannot take it and he loses
consciousness at this point Gohan's
power is nowhere close to where it once
was let alone to where go cos and
Vegeta's powers are since through their
costs and training they have both
attained super saiyan blue after Frieza
succeeds in blowing up the earth and
Weez has to reverse time Gohan realizes
that he has to be much much stronger to
protect the ones he loves and so he
asked for piccolo to train him again
later Gohan is offered a job as a
professor's assistant which would
definitely mean less training and that
is the last thing that those of us who
were worried about how we go on has
gotten wanted luckily he turns the
position down because it would take too
much time away from medellín pan he's
become a family man who spoils his
daughter but he also realizes that he
needs to grow stronger to protect his
family
when Future Trunks comes back to the
present he is surprised that he cannot
detect any of the overflowing energy
that Gohan used to defeat cell there's a
moment when trunks sees Gohan playing
with pan and trunks realizes what life
might have been like if he had come from
a more peaceful future where future
Gohan and him didn't have to constantly
fight and this thought alone brings him
to tears after some moss whose demise we
get news that there is going to be a
great sale man move
where the mass superhero is going to
fight mr. Satan Gohan
as the stunt man quickly outshines
buried the actor who is playing The
Grates a man in the film and Coco the
female lead falls in love with Gohan and
even sneaks a kissing
however Gohan as we know has a pure
heart like Goku and is totally loyal to
the del Barry shows the picture of Coco
kissing Gohan and suggests that Gohan is
having an affair with Coco but Vidal
thinks that Berry is pathetic and
completely trusts Gohan later when Gohan
is fighting Berry who has been infected
by what oh gosh Coco fears for his life
but Vidal believes and Gohan and assures
the actress that Gohan would never allow
himself to lose in front of her Vidal
and pan cheer Gohan on and as a Super
Saiyan he finishes berry off with a
super great salmon beam although there
isn't much serious fighting going on in
these episodes they do a great job of
developing Gohan's relationship with his
family however after that we finally
arrived to the universe survival saga
and Gohan starts fighting seriously
again Goku needs to find two more team
members so that they can show the xenos
a preview of what a martial arts
tournament is Vegeta won't leave Earth
until his new child is born but he
suggests that Goku take Gohan instead
Gohan is hesitant because he's still
rusty but ultimately agrees to fight for
Vidal and pan Gohan fights lavender and
despite being blinded and poisoned is
able to pull off a draw but still can't
push his power beyond the Super Saiyan
later during a sparring match with
Crillon Gohan is defeated when Crillon
knocks him out of bounds using his new
move solar flare times 100
Gohan goes to train with piccolo and
then has a sparring match with Goku
Gohan is able to push Goku to go super
saiyan blue kaio-ken before he is
defeated even the announcer at the
beginning of the following episode said
that Gohan showed power that rivaled
Goku's and he says at last the strong go
hunt has returned which all of us Gohan
fans were absolutely psyched to hear
Gohan is now stronger than ever for the
first time in Super and I cannot be more
excited about it Goku impressed by his
strength and skill even makes Gohan the
leader of the universe 7 team Gohan
wants to surpass even Goku but he wants
to do it in his own way he says that his
goal is an ultimate form that
no one has ever seen before so it's
interesting that even among Saiyans
people do not need to achieve the same
milestones like Super Saiyan blue to
increase their power I'm very excited to
see Gohan realize his ultimate form and
I wouldn't be surprised if he did it
during the tournament of power he's been
putting in a solid performance so far
especially in the more recent episodes
in Dragon Ball Z Gohan despite his age
could pull out immense even
unprecedented power when he was pushed
into a corner and when his loved ones
were in danger Dragon Ball super has
spent a lot of time showing us how much
Gohan cares about the Dallin pant
especially and about how much he wants
to protect them since their very
existence is on the line if universe 7
loses the tournament I feel that Gohan
might be pushed to achieve the new form
he's been talking about in the near
future whether or not he'll surpass Goku
remains to be seen but he's always had
the potential and he has always done so
in Dragon Ball Z so it wouldn't be
anything new if Gohan became one of the
strongest fighters once again let me
know what you guys think in the comment
section we'll go ha never surpass Goku
again and what do you think his new
ultimate form will look like anyways
guys that's it for this video thank you
so much for watching all the way to the
end this was a pretty long one but
there's so much to talk about here we've
literally seen Gohan grow from a baby to
an adult with his own baby if you watch
all the way to the end drop a hashtag
ultimate forum in the comment section to
show your support if you enjoyed this
video be sure to smash that like button
and subscribe for more Dragon Ball super
videos like this one and until next time
see you space Cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]